so I see on your resume you just
graduated college I did I did just
graduate college as [ __ ] laude so what
are some things you learned in college
that you think would apply to this job I
think I learned a lot in college that
would help me in this job a lot of
skills I picked up on I learned things
like teamwork multitasking I think I
learned leadership skill so you're gonna
be the DD tonight yeah you are nose goes
BAM I'm really good with managing money
I am a good problem solver hey Dad I
always had a good academic record so if
I need a 70% to pass the class and I got
a 78 on the paper and that means I only
need a 71 on the final hey guys I'm
going out tonight I'm a good
communicator I have an astounding
perseverance I'm quite the motivator
I love researching things I have good
time management skills I have and yeah I
really think that college prepared me
for this job well everything looks good
except for the fact that this is an
entry-level position and we do require
three years of experience so this won't
work out yeah make sense silly me
you